israël hamas un cessez le feu fragile
c'est l'une des questions de ce débat
auquel participent françois à costantini
géopolitologue et michel raimbault
ancien ambassadeur de france
bonsoir messieurs merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation alors israël et le
hamas ont donc accepté un cessez-le-feu
après 11 jours d'affrontements est ce
qu'on peut croire qu'il va tenir dans le
temps ce cessez-le-feu michel raimbault
je ne crois pas qu'il va tenir dans le
temps il voudrait être du temps parce
que bon c'est pas en fait c'est quoi un
cessez le feu qu'il faudrait un
palestine et en israël
il faudrait cesser l'occupation la
colonisation les implantations
l'humiliation l'oppression le
confinement de la population
palestinienne à gaza
son emprisonnement et l'apartheid
finalement la politique d'apartheid
l'état d'israël est dénoncé par
certaines ong human rights watch
notamment et puis deuxièmement c'est pas
un conflit entre le hamas et vous me
palestiniens se sont tous deux amassé le
hamas et israël
et donc s'il fait des contre le hamas et
israël nous nous le confie sa conscience
tous les palestiniens
je rappellerai que les événements du
moment où commencent et déclencher
l'esplanade des mosquées donc à
jérusalem en tuiles qu'ils ont touché la
bande de gaza bien évidemment et puis
ensuite qu'ils ont touché les places
occupées et la cisjordanie aux étages
aux frontières est allemands y compris
des territoires occupés avec les pays
voisins
la jordanie liban syrie etc france alors
je pense que le cessez le feu cesser
complètement ses cinquièmes sérieux
parce que sa place à du racket pas du
tout durera probablement doute et demain
ou après demain on en parlera plus en
réalité il faut revenir le fond de ma
pensée c'est faux pas de renvoie dos à
dos des deux partenaires conduit avec
240 morts effectivement 2249 en tout
mais il y en a eu là dessus on a eu un
frère parce que la totalité sont des
palestiniens dont le quart sont des
instants qu'on aime ou deux tiers sont
des enfants
rappelons le français potentiellement
rapidement michel hambourg
oui je dirais qu'il faut pas de renvoie
dos à dos donc d'un côté il faut bon il
n'y aura pas de paix sans justice
avec la fin des politiques que je
mentionnais qui brièvement et puis
ensuite pas de sens retour au droit
international c'est bien notamment le
respect des résolutions publication
sunnite sans compter les accords d'oslo
à l'environnement a maintenant à 25 ans
30 ans qui ont été quand même une
monnaie en bateau les organisations à
l'om paix les palestiniens est donc
consacré le droit international ses 30
ans de perdus ou 25 ans tu perdu
globalement je vois pas très bien
comment on peut reprendre la citation
quant au rôle de l'egypte l'egypte
finalement elle est bien sûr on va y
revenir au rôle de données chez françois
costantini vous êtes d'accord avec
michel rambo cessez-le-feu est fragile
qu'est ce qui le menace le plus parce
que en général du trou au loup dont il
croît de parler et pas de concours parce
que nous on joue en fait la situation
que cette surface en 2005
ryan braun qui administre prend
construire de la bande de gaza est
intenable
il évacue le 15 8 coloris seront bien
gardées beaucoup bourran inutile de
fermer gaza de ne plus occuper la nasa
moyennant quoi réfléchir
la conséquence pratique au dialogue
vingt-huit mois après le hamas qui est
beaucoup plus fort que le fatah sur le
terrain prend les armes et expulse
littéralement le fatah de la direction
de gaza donc en fait trois pas ce qu'ils
souhaitaient de façon implicite c'est à
dire l'autorité palestinienne en
cisjordanie israël et le hamas qui tient
gaza mais en effet au droit
international pour venir
et moi je pense que il ya eu peu de
consensus au plan national il ya eu deux
résolutions qui ont compté la résolution
193 de l'assemblée générale des nations
unies en 1945 le plan de partage échoué
mais surtout ambiance familiale sont en
des 167 la résolution 242 que dit elle
elle demande le retrait israélien des
territoires occupés elle est d'ailleurs
beaucoup plus consistant
français qu'en anglais d'où l'utilité
notre langue en termes de traités
internationaux ainsi que des états il
serait palestinien où s établir la
cisjordanie et gaza je fais remarquer au
passage d'ailleurs que pour ce qu'ils
considéraient qu on donnerait beaucoup
aux palestiniens ça ne constitueraient
que 22 % de ce qui a constitué la
palestine mandataire et aux plans de
droit international c'est vrai moi en
fait
il faut en effet faire en sorte qu'ils
seraient le fait des conventions de
genève qui ouvre la pelle pour vous
rappeler bray interdisent formellement
d'installer des colons des populations
sur des territoires occupés donc la
question de jérusalem est validée
d'ailleurs de façon tout à fait anormal
par la cour suprême israélienne doit
être revue en effet on ne peut pas
considérer aujourd'hui la colonisation
puisse continuer et je pense qu'il faut
aujourd'hui il faut que israël que la
colonisation s'est terminé d'ailleurs la
colonisation ne sauve pas israël il ya
deux choses qui sont pas israël
d'ailleurs là dedans l'arme nucléaire et
la colonisation et il faut en quelque
sorte faire une révolution de sécurité
de stratégique de la part des israéliens
pour comprendre s'il voit bien négocié
alors et là dessus je pense alors à
l'issue de ces derniers affrontements
qui ont été meurtriers davantage un côté
palestinien plus de 230 contre 12
côté israélien les deux camps
revendiquent chacun la victoire alors
quel but estime-t-il avoir atteint
michel raimbault
j'ai dit que c'est de bonne guerre non
comme si c'est une feuille de
revendiquer la victoire
on voit pas des gens revendiquent une
défaite jamais entendus samedi d'un
politique né en politique internationale
et la moins effective mans il ya eu des
manifestations de joie parce que le
cessez le feu le ce s'est fait du bien
quand ça s'arrête
et puis d'autre part il donnait
l'impression d'avoir réussi à arracher
un cessez-le-feu en d'autres temps c'est
vrai que le banc les bombardements
allaient continuer à l'impression a
continué comme si de rien n'était là
c'est déjà avoir obtenu en un temps
relativement record à 6 en fait
quelqu'un un succès pour les pour les
mouvements palestiniens les palestiniens
global
le peuple pas seulement programme alors
après pour l'état d'israël j'ai toujours
d'une interminable s'est félicité du
succès de la politique d'israël et de
son côté pacifique et de tout ce qu'elle
n'est pas alors par contre qu'ils
croient encore à la solution à deux
états comme le faisait remarquer
précédente intervenants dont je partage
largement ce qu'est ce qu'il a affirmé
je pense que c'est vrai qu'on ne voit
pas très bien une solution à deux états
sur quelle base quelles bases
territoriales
je crois qu'à peu près à donf erreur de
ma part
disons je pense que les israéliens
contre la peu près ils ont 90 % du
territoire nous à palestine historique
c'est à dire ça ne pas dans le panneau
de partage est donc allé voir s'il nous
évacuer tous les territoires occupés en
1967 de revenir août la ligne verte de
je pense que ça revient à brest une
d'évacuer au moins la moitié du
territoire qu'ils contrôlent
actuellement les goûts on ne voit pas
très bien on ne peut pas très bien
l'état d'israël dans de circonstances
actuelles je résoudre un tel sacrifice
15 heures jusqu'à présent les études
sont vainqueurs et qu'ils peuvent faire
puisqu'ils veulent ils ont été 1 puni
jusqu'à maintenant ils colis ou bien
rester impuni encore dire que les
palestiniens qui peuvent unir
parce que en fait ils ont montré qu'ils
pouvaient comme la terrine grâce dans
l'usb y compris une panique comme
généralisée
disons dans l'état d'israël y compris
dans dans la capitale sur les plages
israël d'en faire cesser la vie
tranquille des israéliens pendant ces
les canapés et population fanta l'égide
je voulais jouer seul dira un seul mot
ce serait très très bref sur l'egypte
mais les bien gentil de leurs
négociations sociales parce qu'elle a un
grave responsabilité dans la situation
de la bande de gaza puisqu'elle aurait
très bien pu ouvrir sa frontière
finalement depuis longtemps on est en
carafe qui se respecte un grand état
arabe n aurait pu faire ça elle n'a
jamais fait et donc elle a coopéré
depuis les accords d'oslo
la solution à deux états la recherche de
solutions politiques s'est avéré être
une grande tromperie
alors je ne sais pas si ça reprendra
cette fois ci après tous les sacrifices
et le calvaire que vivent les
palestiniens et puis depuis tant et tant
d'années y compris depuis les accords
d'oslo
françois costantini vous pensez aussi
que la solution
à deux états est une tromperie ça veut
dire quoi que le conflit israélo
palestinien va s'éterniser dans le temps
il est déjà vieux de plus de 70 ans
maintenant voyons on est très loin de la
solution à deux états je rappelle que
hicks ont conser enlever une frêle
compte contrôler comme d'asus
ambassadeur 90 % si l'on considère en
effet les points de contrôle encore de
la cisjordanie sans les zones mixtes
sans les roannais sebastian mais je
rappelle que si en effet on considérait
que gaza plus la cisjordanie plus
jérusalem est à l'arrêt tapas partie
palestinienne devait constituer un état
se serait 22% au total delà de la
palestine mandataire
je rappelle que lors du partage de 1947
les arabes obtenu 45 % il est vrai que
les israéliens avaient 55 % mais il
avait à l'époque le negev qui ont
constitué la moitié qui était
pratiquement peu plus donc voilà un peu
pour pour relativiser les choses oui je
pense que la situation à deux états je
pense qu'elle est elle est mort né avec
les accords d'oslo tout simplement les
accords d'oslo n'ont pas vécu plus d'un
an 2
il ya eu ensuite les airs on essaie de
rattraper les choses avec les accords de
tabac de daube il est au de barak
mais ça c'est pratiquement et feront des
au monde la deuxième intifada et à plus
forte raison ensuite avec les les
circonstances de l'évaluation de la
bande de gaza et le contrôle du hamas
en effet il faut pas oublier également
que le les palestiniens le hamas d'un
côté l'autorité palestienne sont même
aujourd'hui traversée par ce que
j'appelle à la nouvelle guerre froide
arabe vous avez un mas qui est plutôt
proche de l'iran du qatar soutenu mais
également moins peu utile par erdogan
maire de gagner est la nouvelle
coqueluche aujourd'hui des populations
palestiniens et de l'autre une autorité
palestinienne alors c'est vrai qui a à
bout de bras et soutenu par parce que
j'ai ce que j'appelle pardon le bloc
abraham c'est-à-dire l'arabie saoudite
les émirats les émirats les pays arabes
l'egypte
mais tout cela tout cela est très
fragile et palestiniens sont même déjà
traversé par une fracture interne au
monde arabe on au monde
au monde sunnite au proche-orient-
aujourd'hui c'est dire si la situation
est particulièrement compliqué ne pas
oublier également qu'une anecdote dont
on a peu parlé c'est que il ya quelques
mois
vu la situation dramatique au au plan
social oprean alimentaire sanitaire à
gaza c'est sous d'ailleurs l'accord
israélien que le qatar a versé à un
milliard de dollars pour essayer de
soutenir en quelque sorte la société
gazaouie pour dire un peu si si si les
choses sont compliquées en tout cas
particulier compromis je crois qu'on est
pour moi dans un espace partir mans
fragmenté et qu'on est très très loin de
la solution à deux états en effet alors
michel raimbault et puis ce sera le mot
de la fin
qu'est ce qu'on peut dire du rôle de la
diplomatie internationale alors à chaque
fois les états unis usent de leur veto
pour empêcher toute résolution 1
condamnant les agissements de l'armée
israélienne ça veut dire qu l'issue de
ce conflit ne passera pas par l'onu
écoutez il faudrait que ça passe par
l'eau est nul puisque israël est un état
créé par leurs nuls que les violences et
les résolutions 1953 sans une résolution
de recommandations du conseil de
sécurité l'assemblée générale viennent
et on verra comment expliquer sa
passivité sac ou presque bienveillance à
l'égard de l'état occidentaux avec les
états unis à commencer par les états
unis ne sont pas neutres en la matière
ce ne sont pas un honnête négociateurs
disons qu'il soit aligné totalement sur
les castrais je dis ça c'est pas
seulement vernon gouvernements
américains successifs toutes les
administrations démocrates c'est bonnet
blanc et blanc bonnet et les pays
occidentaux également commencer par la
france la grande-bretagne bien
évidemment mais aussi tous les autres et
m issu comme un troupeau de moutons dix
ans les états unis et qui sont prêts à
se plier à toutes étant les etats-unis
changerait de politique drastiquement et
bien la lumière qu'elle ne ferait dans
la douleur et dans la demi heure mais là
comme ça ne sera pas le cas
manifestement ce ne sera jamais le cas
pour l'union européenne l'union
européenne donnait le change en faisant
des déclarations flamboyantes et les
martiales mais notez que les états unis
la voix est bien mignon tous les états
européens entrent dans le rang à
commencer par la france la grande
bretagne et d'autres et tous les pains
ont fait les grands titres européens
c'est un peu désespérant
je pense que les palestiniens doivent
pas attendre grand chose au fond ils
sont sérieux des européens et ne rien
attendre du tout des américains ils sont
sérieux à présent peut continuer à leur
diffusion
et puis croire que malgré ça changera
avec le temps à lui à l'échelle
géologique certainement à l'échelle
politique et géopolitique
je ne sais pas le chef géopolitique je
ne sais pas mais à l'échelle politique
qu'elle est chez lui même à ça je crois
que ça ne changera pas dans l'avenir que
c'est seulement au fond la lune minutes
en un conflit qui peut régler ça je ne
suis pas du tout belliciste chez les
minis trainer de sabre et je déteste la
guerre mais globalement je pense que la
situation actuelle ne peut dire ce
réduite par la négociation pour être
deux pour négocier on a ri à oslo avec
les palestiniens qui négocier et en fait
je pense qu'on peut douter de la volonté
est l'état d'israël il n'a pas de
frontières mais qui entend pas sans
donner la meilleure façon de ne pas se
retourner
c'est de me donner c'est tout ça en flou
avec des zones a b c
j'ai contrôlé finalement le lancement
d'une application mais cela renvoie à
l'interview touche à sa fin merci
d'avoir accepté d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
ancien ambassadeur de france merci à
vous également françois costantini vous
êtes géopolitologue merci beaucoup